[Musica]
io sono un instancabile sognatore e ho
iniziato da qua
qui e quando ho immaginato di essere un
futuro presidente del consiglio
io sogno nel 2029 di essere il premier
italiano
ho immaginato di essere il futuro
presidente del consiglio perché tutti
penso che un giorno di poter diventare
astronauti che pompiere i dottori
nessuno vuole fare presente al consiglio
io si è però oggi non vi parlo di questo
che non vi parlerò nemmeno delle persone
che ho incontrato io vi parlerò della
potenza dell'incontro e vi parlerò
dell'arcobaleno
a me non piacciono gli arcobaleni
non mi piacciono perché non sono capaci
di vedere nella bellezza però ama
immaginarli ama immaginarli negli
incontri con le persone ma soprattutto
l'arcobaleno è qualcosa che si può
descrivere al meglio l'incontro come una
persona immaginatevi elementi per far sì
che nasca un arcobaleno non basta
osservare abbiamo bisogno dell'acqua e
l'acqua è l'elemento vitale è un
elemento importante
l'acqua non è solo in natura e nel
nostro corpo e poi abbiamo bisogno della
luce perché la luce è quell'elemento che
dà gioia bellezza ed è quell'elemento
che ti permette poi di dar risalto a
quello che può essere o meno anche solo
una goccia d'acqua
l'arcobaleno noi lo viviamo lo possiamo
vedere nelle persone lo possiamo
osservare soprattutto lo osserviamo
quando camminando ci accorgiamo che dopo
una tempesta quando rinasce il sole
osserviamo delle luci e man mano che noi
ci avvicinammo dal sull'arcobaleno poi
dopo un po sparisce poi dopo un po
ricompare poi come un po sparisce poi
dopo un po di compare perché
l'arcobaleno è qualcosa che non è fisso
per cercare l'arcobaleno bisogno di
muovermi
ho bisogno di spostarmi in una direzione
o bisogno di cambiare prospettiva e
quindi immaginate di applicare questo
nell'incontro e prova data contarvi il
perché io in tutti gli incontri che
faccio con qualsiasi persona cerco di
cercare l'arcobaleno l'arcobaleno sette
colori
io sono partito dall ultimo il viola il
viola indica mistero prima di contrarre
una persona voi quella persona non
necessariamente la conoscete vi fate un
idea
provate a pensare come quella persona
può pensare ragionare immaginare un
qualcosa prima di contrarre una persona
a voi pensate di sapere già qualcosa di
quella persona magari adatta a cercare
in internet
se esiste qualche informazione mai
mandate cercare un informazione
particolare cercate di conoscere e di
individuare un sapere una conoscenza
particolare perché voglio tornare a qui
perché vi devo dare la definizione
dell'arcobaleno perché l'arcobaleno è un
fenomeno ottico o meglio questo c'è
scritto quando voi andate a cercare
arcobaleno la come un fenomeno ottico
che produce uno spettro quasi continuo
di luce nel cielo quando la luce del
sole attraverso le gocce d'acqua
rimaste in sospensione e quello che
rimane in sospensione è il mistero
dopodiché se quell idea se si supera la
fase di mistero con una persona e quindi
ho immaginato di essere quantomeno un
pochino più vicino con la persona iniziò
a parlare di idee e se c'è la
condivisione di idee
l'idea non nascono dal nulla l'idea
nasce dal sapere
iniziamo a condividere conoscenze e se
condividiamo conoscenze allora significa
che stiamo trovando un punto di incontro
perché significa che noi siamo più su
due piani completamente separati e su
due piani paralleli ma siamo lì
sulla stessa lunghezza d'onda
abbiamo superato il mistero abbiamo
parlato di idee abbiamo condiviso il
nostro sapere e la condivisione deve ora
arrivare all'esterno insieme con le
persone e con i quali abbiamo ci siamo
incontrati dobbiamo iniziare a parlare
fuori dobbiamo iniziare a capire se la
nostra condivisione di idee di saperi
conoscenze può creare qualcosa per gli
altri
ed è qui che nasce la fiducia e la
fiducia il giallo nel giallo perché apre
si allarga se io mi fido di una persona
si libera che mi fido abbastanza per
poter iniziare a svolgere un'azione con
quella persona mi metto in moto e faccio
qualcosa e se io inizio a fare un
qualcosa mi aspetto di avere successo
non è il mio successo personale non è il
successo della persona che ho incontrato
è successo è quella cosa che insieme
unendo tutti i passaggi dal mistero
dall'idea da sapere dalla condivisione
dalla
luce dall'azione successo il successo
quella cosa che si crea insieme è quella
cosa che ci siamo incontrati abbiamo
superato le nostre barriere e abbiamo
fatto qualcosa
già solo il fatto che si è fatto
qualcosa insieme
significa che quella relazione avuto
successo ma non necessariamente con
successo abbiamo cercato abbiamo trovato
l'arcobaleno tra le due persone perché
esiste un secondo esercizio da fare
povera individuare se se si è acqua così
se luce perché se sia acqua significa
che in quell'incontro c'è qualcuno che
arriva forte come una tempesta oppure ti
permette di rimanere in vita perché ti
disse tra allora se sei acqua
all'interno di quell'incontro il tuo
pensiero deve diventare quello di ok ma
cosa succede nel momento in cui incontrò
una persona che è luce per me cosa
succede nel momento in cui io incontro
quella persona che mi permette di o
dissetare gli altri poi di far accadere
tempeste e si seduce che seduce bisogna
individuare se all'interno di una stanza
io riesca a far brillare gli altri
allora li e da potenza dell'incontro se
nel momento in cui entro gli altri si
illuminano e se gli altri si illumina
bisogna capire chi dentro quella stanza
e acqua
perché se individuiamo le persone e ogni
incontro lo immaginiamo come devo capire
ci sono accorso una luce allora io posso
permettermi di capire quello che è il
passo successivo perché la potenza
dell'incontro è sempre una ricerca
dell'arcobaleno
io nella mia vita avevo 26 anni ho avuto
la possibilità di incontrare tantissime
persone persone che questo mondo da
hanno influenzato in positivo
chi più chi meno ho avuto la possibilità
di cenare con barack obama ho avuto la
possibilità di avere una cena privata e
di parlare per tre ore con un premio
nobel per la pace mamma di nus prima 9
per la pace nel 2006 ho stretto la mano
a ban ki moon
ho avuto una conversazione di 10 minuti
con tim cook e dalla apple
e così via ma non è quello l'elemento di
distinzione non è quella la potenza
dell'incontro quello un acceleratore mi
ha permesso poi di poter avere la
possibilità di incontrare tantissime
altre persone e dedico 40 giorni
all'anno a incontrare persone di cui non
so assolutamente nulla persone che mi
scrivono online e mi chiedono ciò
valentino ho letto la tua storia
per me tu sei di ispirazione io allora
rispondo
scegli un giorno sceglie una città
incontriamoci tu per me può essere
ispirazione perché la tua storia non la
conosco
tu la mia la retta ma io voglio dalla
tua la voglio sentirmi da dire bisogna
capire se in quella persona e in quella
circostanza
io la possibilità di andare oltre non
posso fermarmi a pensare che io sono
luce l'altra persona e acqua o viceversa
il mio pensiero deve viaggiare oltre
devo capire dietro quella persona che
cosa che cosa che cosa resta
devo capire qual è la mia azione
successiva
devo capire cosa ci permette a superare
ogni tipo ogni tipo di fase ogni colore
dal mistero dall'idea dalla condivisione
del sapere dalla condivisione di tutto
quello che è successo prima
dall'azione al successo
ho bisogno di capire se quella persona
poi ha la possibilità di essere
d'impatto per tante altre persone mai
ragionare con io possa essere importante
per loro
noi possiamo essere importanti per tante
altre persone io da solo possa essere
importante per una persona perché io
prima di essere importante per lui sono
stato importante per qualcun altro
e poi qualcun altro qualcun altro ancora
è perché qualcuno mi ha fatto pensare a
quanto essere il più possibile incisivo
per gli altri dedico gran parte del
tempo a raccontare di storie e di
ascoltarne tante altre
ascoltate ascoltate quello che vi arriva
dentro in ogni parola che una persona vi
racconta iniziate a pensare quello che
può essere all'interno del vostro io la
vostra parte di colore
cercate di essere positivi sorridete e
non prendetevi sul serio perché siamo
comunque umani io sono un essere umano
come qualsiasi persona in questa stanza
è l'essere umano che fa la differenza
potete chattare con centinaia migliaia
di persone
potete sentirle via skype potete parlare
con loro in qualsiasi tipo di mezzo ma
l'incontro con una persona determinerà
se o meno può nascere un arcobaleno tra
le due persone l'incontro con una
persona ti permette di individuare o
meno se tutte le sette fasi si possono
completare perché se non ci si incontra
non superiamo mai la fase del mistero se
non ci incontriamo
non abbiamo la possibilità di
condividere delle idee
nel momento in cui il nostro pensiero il
viaggia nello stesso istante se non ci
incontriamo
non abbiamo la possibilità di
condividere il sapere che nasce in
quella stanza in quel momento in
quell'incontro se non ci incontriamo
non possiamo fare un'azione se non ci
incontriamo nel nostro incontro non può
succedere e non succederà un successo
vuol dire che non abbiamo avuto impatto
per gli altri
siate sognatori
io sono un instancabile sognatore ma
cercate l'arcobaleno
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]